next question today hey David I noticed
that you don't use some of the Soviet
terminology that is becoming in vogue
with part of the left like calling
people comrades and talking about things
being read in a positive way why don't
you use that terminology
listen I've sort of talked about this
before I'm not a communist I'm not a
socialist I don't think that Leninism or
Stalinist Marxism are the directions
that we should be going as a society my
model is one of social democracy taking
many of the elements that have worked
well in Scandinavian northern European
countries and tweaking them and doing
things that account for the reality that
the United States is more diverse than a
lot of those countries and the United
States has a lot of different other
cultural elements going on so that
that's basically my model I don't look
back at the Soviet Union with
rose-colored glasses or in this
nostalgic way you know in the same way
that the right talks about the golden
age of the 1950's or whatever and I just
think that doesn't make any sense I also
don't look back at the Soviet era and
say that's what we should be striving
for so I don't know who you're referring
to
the only thing I can think of is I know
that Hasan [ __ ] from The Young Turks
from TYT Network has or had a show
called agitprop and okay I mean you know
call the show what you want I don't know
that that's necessarily what I would
call a show I don't need to make
reference to Soviet terminology I don't
know of anybody who calls others
comrades but I believe you that it
exists it's just not interesting to me
you know I don't I don't think my
movement and the policy and ideas that I
support of economic justice and
welfare programs that work and lifting
people up and reducing inequality and
fixing a lot of the things that aren't
working I don't think I need Soviet
terminology to make that a reality I
don't think that it helps and also the
other thing is in general I'm not that
big a fan aside from Soviet terminology
when I'm trying I am a progressive I
want to move forward so in general I
don't see the world as here's the phase
we want to go back to we need to be
moving forward we might incorporate
incorporate economic or cultural or
societal elements from some time in the
past which might have overlap with some
other movement or country or era or
phase and that's fine but for me as a
progressive I'm seeing us going to
something new and unprecedented so it's
against my nature to say let's call each
other comrades or let's do our agitprop
or use Soviet terminology because I'm
not looking to go back to something I
might incorporate things that worked
from the past but I'm looking to go
forward and to something new so I'm not
particularly interested in adopting old
terminology when what I want to do is
actually see progress as the word
progressive contains within it
etymologically if that is if that is a
word so that's my view